ist man schlauer pitzling der fachwerk
aufmerksamkeits beruf oder bist du so
etwas wie eine kunstaktion leben
abgeschlagen die werk einfach mehr leute
begreifen dass man regeln - aber
kompromiss sucht
politiker
und kathi
[Musik]
ja heute neue flaschenpost mit dem auto
und mit mehrere zum thema aktivismus und
zivilem kurs haben und zur frage nach
gott für die gute sache war bis zuletzt
aber da der
regen der ukraine und frauen muss
natürlich
finde ich
finde
klar angeführt finde ich was war das
privileg system drei landsleute wo du
überhaupt aber er muss rasch und es ist
sehr stark
was es heißt bürger und bürgerinnen die
partnerin eine bürgerversammlung also so
schön geschrieben der performative akte
der straße gemeinsam
die ihren anfang in stockach idstein ii
demokratie
[Musik]
wo du gar nicht zustimmen
thema sind auf der politischen agenda
aktivismus im mieter sind aber vor allem
aber das was man sagen nennt und das ist
ja mehr oder besorgen da saßen demo das
impliziert nämlich ein rechtsbruch also
mir macht es auf dem
corsa genau und dass das auch öffentlich
passiert mit dem verborgen haben haben
sich zum beispiel bewusst auf der
terrasse hat verschiedene kriterien
aufgestellt rechtsbruch in einer
öffentlichen 8 und es dient dem zweck
die miniatur geschwänzt auch
wenn sie über den pflicht bruch aber
dient im 2 das einfach capo caccia
besonders wenn quasi 20 mit greta
nürnberg aber das braucht zum drucken
sie üben und viele andere jugendliche
sind jeder gefolgt vom druck auf
regierung
ist es natürlich auch wenn du in der
lounge wo du dir 8
wenn du die
ganze platte eigentlich
stand
goldrichtig die vielen und
thüringens grüne quark historische nacht
das öffentliche die symbolisch wirklich
sind immer und andern ist das
frühzeitige out oder
also das
extension rebellion
klimaschutzorganisation ist wo kannst
gab es sterben oder berlin extensions
starter rebellion dass man mit uns
startet die bekleidet sehr stark
verkauft haben und wichtig ich habe
wirklich meistens fünf elemente
die lehren so seminar teilnehmen
so achtet und lotto vectra dass es nicht
zu handgreiflichkeiten
nicht dass polizei muss mit gewalt
intervenieren oder das rückschlag oder
sachbeschädigung gemacht die das mikro
kloster stehen wo wir
sind ist getrieben
kritik
diener werde gestopft und wovon er
widerstand und das finde ich es
interessant
moment ich
danke den emotionen
so bestimmungen besagen dass ich bin
wirklich spielen kann sich umgebracht im
wallis in 257 remy cointreau gab es acht
vom wallis kommunale stimm und wahlrecht
der frauen gehabt also da
gerichtsentscheiden kanton verstoßen hat
und mit thema beraten
darüber diskutiert wurde nicht auch das
raue stimme achten ist die europäische
super punkt also
sind der fehler errungenschaft dass frau
erreicht das bürgerrecht in ein so
angefangen nicht mit legaler menschen
sondern in dem leicht braafheid wird es
zwar diskriminierend sei erklärte
zwanziger befragung des
entwicklungsstandes und ich krieg dich
schlecht darüber diskutieren ob es
demokratische mit prozent das zur
demokratie
team ratio sieht das letzte mittel sie
das gehört dazu
so strache sondern eigentlich täuscht
illegale mittels
stativ der schweiz haben sie die
möglichkeit initiative zum beispiel die
schlagworte aber es gibt natürlich hat
jeder situation und muss sagen es ist an
und du und sagt zum beispiel der hamas
es gehört zum relief für politische
demokratischer kultur dass man zwischen
den unkosten zu laut werde neben einer
gruppe geht wo verlierer doch nicht so
kamen die minderjährige erwähnt sondern
auch zeitlich sind juni kann mitmachen
und die waren zu bringen das mit
tolerieren aber durch
die initiative saubere politik komme ich
eigentlich
abc der fachwerk aufmerksamkeits beruf
oder bist du so etwas wie eine
kunstaktion leben
die ausstellung die werke nach mehr
leute greifen
wir die mühsamen kompromiss zu
politiker
und katheter die dringlichkeit ich
darüber rede ich dringlichkeit das kurz
politisch mittel aber für sie ist es
extrem wichtig und ganz deutlich und es
ist absolut richtig dass ein klimaziel
afrika immer einfach noch mal wieder in
die haut wird sie über diese
klimaabkommens wieder und das tempo und
sagt sie das ist ein siedlung noch
machen und scor
krankheitserreger dem das macht richtig
finde der mann muss man auch sieht oft
institutionen schützen an sich wenn ein
rechtsstaat besteht aus hoch scottish
das haben wir zu spüren
wo es weit über tyrannei der kürzlich
aus grafiken als wunderschönes durchwegs
nur jedem haus herzlaker und er betont
dass ganz fest institutionen schützen
ist extrem wichtig und das wird
interessant wenn man über uns geredet
und über widerstand rettet und über
tyrannei redet mit einem schweizer
institutionen aber sind punkt ist
natürlich das ganze stadt kroatische
regime auf erst die institutionen klima
hat und das leben in polen das leben in
ungarn streben in russland stream
itk-branche schranken richtig schranke
und sowie institutionen sind ganz ganz
wichtigen institution das er liebte und
korrupte
zwischen institutionen
natürlich sie stehen plötzlich
übernehmen das autoritäre systeme
diktaturen tyrannen und die
institutionen komplett ausgehöhlt sind
denn die vielen kurs an den gott und
widerstand und politische widerstand ein
gott strunz politische sie stehen
entweder wieder herstellen das forex
oder revolution arzt dass es wieder rund
und das ist doch interessant nun kann
dort eigentlich mit revolution zivilen
opfer seien dort von dem getriebe
eigentlich sie stehen sagt jetzt mode
demokratie bewahren
aber trainer gewisse sachen freunde und
jetzt wird es interessant oder wir
klimabewegung zum teilzeit system change
war es gerade mit einer
demokratiekrise und in öko diktatur aber
ich finde uns steht extrem wichtig also
es gibt natürlich widerstand vor 8 uhr
im grundpaket institutionen schließt gar
derart stark ist und nicht
alle menschen
versucht wir
selbst gerade alle anderen oder so hat
wissen und zwar kein mittel die
diskussion haben wir den raum sowie
jugend also überlegt doch mal wenn das
mal nicht fertig er musste sie überhaupt
da war es ist ein eigentlichen zweck so
dass acht fertiggebracht abend die
vielen käufern natürlich möglichst
darüber und was sind gute zweck die
mittel sind denn dann wiederum
traktieren nach aber die diskussion
kommen nicht von vornherein sagen
definieren so
agitation in der aktion also in dem du
mitmachst kundtun 1 10 das
projekt über
das glaube erste aktion
aber ich finde psychologisch trifft
etwas das du eventuell auch schon die
energie gespürt dennoch irgendwie auch
für fonds unter dem motto bis überhaupt
zeigt mir dass wir die körperliche
soziale wesen absolut das erinnere mich
noch mal mit den ganzen sachen für
amerikanische schriftsteller und sehe
jetzt gab der klimawandel und frauen in
trachten er gegen hier propagiert er
geschieht das auseinander und ich muss
einfach gut division bänder um
frauengeschichten wurde ich erfasse den
wahlen und der beliebtesten stadien oder
wenn eine wahl gemacht dass er fast gar
nicht anders mitmachen und dass ich an
hier seid und jetzt vorstellt er
unbedingt da und er ist sekunden ist ein
opfer sondern das rund und fristig
mitverfasst groß
die werden
natürlich
die ganzen jugend bewegt
frisch die engagement schlägt
aber grundsatz muss ich schon sagen
wie
politisch aktiv jugend zu
achten die dringlichkeit wo sie
zu finden ist nicht
einfach in schwarz und so ganz verstehen
ist extrem ernst und setzt viel zeit und
energie für elia lecker und angesichts
der tatsache dass es wird zukünftig
erhöht darüber entscheidet muss ich
sagen ist die acht ich ja wie stellt er
zu aktivismus und zivilem ungehorsam
vivico 7 kommentare und wenn dann müsste
zudem eine zweitsprache anderem
sozialphilosoph robin celik art dass sie
wieder und haben uns sprach dissident
und wenn er nüchtern so besser
vergleichen boss hat erklärte kann